I think you do have like the highest
profile of the Workaholics guys I mean
you've done you know you know you've
been in other projects outside of there
that have have a lot of notoriety is
there competition among you guys or was
there like is it kind of went on was it
like so and so it's getting more you
know Andrew's getting more attention
than me you know uh no and I I mean I
think we're we're like brothers so like
there's there's some like we're like a
band I feel like that's how we explain
it uh and there's
you know there's fighting but it's never
really about uh about that kind of stuff
yeah like the Hollywood stuff we usually
keep that out I'm probably I probably
have the biggest ego out of all of us
and I'm not that crazy so like I'm the
egomaniac out of the four of us
is also in checks but you've also been
around some egomania oh yeah no I'm not
I'm like guys I'm not that bad oh yeah
yeah I'm not that bad there's lots of
people in this town that make you feel
like
like oh yeah okay I'm not a Monster yeah
anytime I think I'm a monster all I
gotta do is remember that person
um and who is that person
look at the scars yeah
he has me on a choke on a on a buzz
collar he zaps it whenever he feels like
um when you started to get acting roles
outside of where you just come in and
say the words like how do you like that
as opposed to the things where you get
to be a producer and a writer on things
yeah it's uh you know it's way easier
and sometimes it's nice to come in and
just be like if you like the project
you're you're comfortable with the
people yeah you think that whoever's
steering the ship is doing a good job uh
and you're confident in their abilities
then then it's fun yeah and every once
in a while you you'll sign on the thing
and and you're like oh you get halfway
into it and you're like oh no this is a
sinking ship what did I do but yeah I
would say for them most part uh is as
long as you did the due diligence of
really
vetting everything before before signing
up for it uh yeah I've really enjoyed it
yeah it is really good the righteous
gems uh you know I mean being on the
righteous gemstone oh that's easy it was
an easy that's the easy one that's all
the Pitch Perfect movies you know it's
like you get to be really really funny
but you don't have the burden of of
leading it yeah yeah exactly uh yeah and
I mean especially with the gemstones it
was like
uh Dana McBride was such a like a hero
of mine early on when we were doing
sketch comedy we got a copy of Foot Fist
Way yeah and I remember we watched it
and we're like oh and not to take any
way anything away from Danny and Jody
Hill who directed it but it was like it
felt like something that we could do it
felt like it was obtainable yeah no like
Will Ferrell and those guys like it felt
since they're doing these big characters
and that's not really what we did it
didn't feel obtainable right
um so yeah so that was an easy one but
with workahol or with uh sorry with
Pitch Perfect it was like a conversation
I had with the guys it was uh I I got
offered it and uh I came to the guys I'm
like yeah they offered me this movie um
and it was after I think we had we were
shooting season two at the time yeah and
uh I'm like yeah I'll shoot this like
right after season two raps and um I
gave this script to blakenders and uh
durs red part of it and he's like dude I
think you you're gonna do really really
well on this it feels like you could
just be really funny and not like you
said not have the burden of carrying the
whole damn thing and then Blake came
into my room late that night we were
working and he's like man you can't do
this
you can't do this and I'm like what and
he's like this is gonna ruin all of us
if you like we're on like the cool hit
like comedy like culty comedy show and
you're gonna go like be a song and dance
man you're gonna be an acapella a singer
yeah and uh thank God I didn't take his
advice right right no yeah because
that really that movie like truly
changed my life it's I mean you I you
know how it is it's Hollywood is a weird
place where there's like Gatekeepers
yeah and the internet has changed a lot
of that but uh there still are
Gatekeepers where in order to be in
movies you someone has to let you in and
then once you're in that movie has to be
a hit yeah and then you have to be the
like a Shining Light Within the movie so
everything just clicked into place at
the right time yeah and then after that
people were like all right he can be in
movies
did Blake ever uh apologize
vehemently still says to this day does
not remember this at all he's like dude
that didn't happen I'm like it happened
Blake and he's like nah that never
happened I'm like yeah yeah
well I mean I can you know because I
remember when that movie came out I was
like acapella like who wants to see that
and then it's so funny it's so I mean
you know I was actually just gonna uh my
fiance and I have a three-year-old and I
was gonna put it on because oh she likes
musical stuff and then I was like oh
yeah but there's lots of filthy filthy
language in that you know and like so
yeah maybe that was that that was not
ready for Fat Amy or whatever that's
what made me sign on to it I was like
okay well it is really funny yeah yeah
yeah yeah absolutely yeah yeah so that
yeah it uh I mean thank God for it